Before we speak to Doctor
[UNKNOWN],
let's discuss the basics of Operant Conditioning. Now Operant Conditioning
looks at consequences of behavior. We have the A, B, C's of Operant
Conditioning. The A is the antecedent. There has to be a queue and a motivation
to perform the behavior. As you will see, Doctor
[UNKNOWN]
uses a target as the queue. The fish reward or the praise is the motivation to
do the behavior. One thing we should note is that fish is a primary reinforcer
and praise is a secondary reinforcer. So food would be a primary reinforcement
because we need it. Praise is a secondary or conditioned reinforcer because we
learn to enjoy praise. Next we have B, which as you might have guessed, is
behavior. The behavior you saw on the first clip was a kiss from Saki, the sea
lion. And finally, C, which is the consequence. By getting the fish or the
praise, we increase the likelihood of repeating the behavior in the future. So
in this case with the kiss, the consequence was something good. Saki received
praise and a fish for giving the kiss. However, if the consequence for the kiss
was something bad, it would decrease the likelihood of the behavior.